- [Announcer] Get up on
your feet, Gary Vaynerchuk.
(cheering and applause)
- [Man] Thank you,
you changed my life.
- [Man 2] I love you, Gary.
- Love you back, thank you.
Thank you.
(cheering)
- [Woman] Love you, Gary.
(cheering and applause)
- Thank you, Vancouver.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, let's do this.
I mean look, we could
stay here all day and do that,
but I want to bring some value.
Yeah, so listen I think we're
doing a pretty cool format.
We're gonna go 20-20-20.
I'm gonna yap here a little bit,
then we're gonna do a
quick little fireside.
Then we'll do some
questions with you guys.
Thank you for the love.
I think that that
moment in itself is something
that I think
everybody should think about.
A funny thing happens
when you do the right thing.
A funny thing
happens when you over-deliver
to the others
and try to take less.
A funny thing happens
when you deploy patience
and run a marathon.
A funny thing happens
and what happens is you start
building equity,
you start building legacy,
you start building leverage.
That reaction I appreciate
and I know and have seen it
for others.
But I know the
reason I get that reaction
and it's not because of my
skill set on a sporting field
or how I sing.
It comes from the
fact that I'm desperately,
and I mean desperately
trying to figure out how
to bring value to you.
I've been thinking about
it a lot which is like hey,
why am I playing this patient?
Why am I not looking
for anything in return?
Why do I like it better
if I give you a whole bunch
and you never give me anything?
And I mean that.
And by the way I'm not
this great human being.
It's not that I'm the
nicest guy in the world.
There's something behind it.
I'm a businessman, I have
my own goals and ambitions.
So I've been really
trying to reverse engineer like
why is this my state?
What makes me
different in this way?
And the other
people that I see do it,
why do they do it?
I think it comes
up to this, my friends.
I think first and foremost,
and this is so important
for so many of you to
hear and I've been saying it
a bunch and I know there's by
the way a lot of engagement
on social so I know a lot
of you have context on me.
I spend the first
13, 14 years of my career
building a business and
not worrying about building
a personal brand and not
having a social media account.
I was building
an actual business.
I think the real reason I give
away my content for free,
I engage with all of you.
I answer, I give love.
I think the biggest reason
I do that is 'cause I don't
need your help or
money to accomplish my goals.
I have enough talent to
build businesses that are not
predicated on turning
admiration or attention
into short-term dollars.
I think this is very important
because if this conference
is positioned as
how do we build things
and have great impact,
it starts with only two things.
There's only two things.
Listen, my whole
talk given the framework
that they've created for
this conference is actually
very simple.
I was thinking about it,
I'm like okay
let's make it contextual.
Let's talk about
something slightly different.
It's actually very easy if
you're sitting in this audience
to achieve the ambition of the
context of this conference,
which is to do things
that are also then good
for humanity.
It's actually very, very simple.
It's two things.
It's intent and this
is a big one and we don't
talk about it enough
in our business world,
entrepreneurship,
tech, solopreneur, intent.
Like what are
you actually up to?
What are you
actually trying to do?
Is your intent to
actually build a great business
and give back to the world?
Or is your intent to disguise
that you want to make money
by saying that every
time somebody buys one
of your granola bars you donate
a granola bar to the hungry?
And I'm glad that eight
of you laughed over there
because I'm going
to tell you something.
As somebody who was
there and saw Blake early on
when he formed
that TOMS shoes model
and as somebody who's an
angel investor in 2013 and '14
and looking at
every single company,
I saw an ungodly amount
of 23-year-olds claiming to me
that because they're
Millennials, this was the best,
this was my favorite pitch.
Because they were
Millennials they cared
about the world more
and so they both wanted
to make money but also they
cared more about the world
than Gen X,
which was really cute.
Then I would look
at their business model
and whatever the fuck
they were selling that they
were then donating one
to somebody that was so
fucking needy, right?
And literally, if you pressed
them on why it was going
to this country, if
you even asked one question
why it was going
to this country,
you pretty much ended up
realizing they just
threw a fucking dart at a map.
(audience laughter)
Then I just want to remind
everybody I'm a businessman.
I understand that
I put out content,
but I'm a businessman.
So it wasn't very difficult
for me to look at the P&amp;L
and the projections to
realize that they were selling
this granola bar, or umbrella,
or sneaker for twice
the price that it needed
to be so they could afford
to actually give the sneaker.
So what you were doing
actually was your intent
was to look like a good person
but still make as much money.
Every dollar that you
would have if you didn't
have the bullshit model that
you were donating something.
So what you were were
completely full of fucking shit.
(audience cheers and applause)
And I have great news.
I searched a lot of
accounts on my long-ass flight
to Vancouver last night of
people using hashtags here.
These are wonderful
people that are in the audience
using the hashtag and they're
going to change the world
and bring to humanity.
And some of you
are full of shit.
(audience laughter)
So if we're going
to accomplish something
from this conference
these two days of inspiration
and good stuff,
if you're gonna
actually accomplish something
when you walk out there and
go back to your normal lives,
I promise you step one
of the idea really good part
of the strategy needs
to be your actual intent.
I want to remind
everybody that it is very okay
to be selfish and build
something and do it in parallel.
You don't need to disguise
your ambitions and wants
and needs with horseshit
that you're going to donate
to the rain-fucking-forest.
(audience laughter)
You don't have to do that.
You're capable of
both, and I am that.
I live it.
I tell you from,
I always talk about stuff
that's real to me.
I am an assassin, killer,
ninja, selfish winner
in business and I can
separate that from who I am.
I want to remind everybody
my favorite all-time thing
of doing good is when somebody
called me out on Twitter
for not donating to
things or doing GoFundMe's
on social media.
That I was a bad guy.
And I literally DM'ed
this person and met him
at Starbucks where I
stopped in between that meeting.
This is back in 2011.
I stopped at my accountant's,
picked up my tax,
yeah picked up my tax returns.
You like this story,
this is a good one.
This is my favorite but I don't
tell this story very often.
But it's good under
the context of this.
He said, "GaryVee, why don't
you donate and do good causes?
"You're just selfish, you
just care about yourself.
"Why don't you do things like
your friends on social media?"
And he mentioned some
social media influencers.
I DM'ed him, I said, "Hey fuck
face, meet me at Starbucks."
(audience laughter)
I went to my accountant's,
I picked up my tax returns,
I showed up to the Starbucks.
He walked in, he shit
that I was actually there.
And then I showed
him my tax return.
Then I said to him,
"Young man here's the difference
"between you and I.
"You're still of the age where
people trick you easily,
"where people use
social media to PR themselves
"and are using causes
to build themselves up
"that they're good people,
and you're confused.
"When you do good you
stay quiet about that shit."
I showed ...
(audience applause and cheers)
You guys know me,
you guys know me.
I'm very comfortable to be
loud and proud of my vanity
and my kind of
like accomplishments.
And I self-promote.
But the things that I'm
most proud of you don't know
jack shit about, you don't.
So I showed him my
tax return which you know,
shows your donations
and how you actually roll.
And he was like,
"I'm so confused."
And I said, "You're confused
because you don't understand
"what's actually happening."
That's the point
of this intent talk.
Nobody in here is tricking
the one percent of winners
with their bullshit.
So if you want to
actually accomplish the thesis
of this conference,
you need to make sure
that your intent is pure.
Your intent, the
way you make your money,
the way you make your money
is something you're proud of.
That you're not bottom
feeding, and most of all
if you're going to do
good for the world, just do it.
Don't use it as your PR engine
to make money on the side.
Intent.
(audience cheering and applause)
It's true, and
I'm sure you've sniffed it out.
Number two, the only
other way to do this whole thing
is my favorite part.
The doing the work.
You know, before you
can help the elephants
and before you're
going to help carrots,
you actually have to
be in a position to help.
The way you do
that is create the means
and the infrastructure to help.
Whether that is a
voice and an audience,
whether that's
the financial means,
whether that's the
relationships, everybody here,
and when I say everybody here
I don't mean this conference,
I mean the whole fucking game.
99% of people are so
quick to get to this thing
that they don't
lay a foundation down.
You gotta
actually build a business
that gives you that air cover.
I wanna remind everybody
here, and it's really fun
because I always love
when the mix of the crowd
is 18 and 88.
(audience laughter)
Because if you're under
26 years old, you've not,
27 years old, you've not lived
through a tough economy yet.
It's been all upswing
since you've been in the game.
Just has, 2008, '09,
like call it what it is,
in 2010 it was
already on it's way up.
Simple as that.
So you're looking
in seven, eight years,
really means you're actually 30
and you haven't really played.
I look around and I see
people more my age and older.
We've been through
some shit, couple of cycles.
We know what happens.
Do you know how excited I am
for the world to collapse soon
so I can get rid of so
many of you fake fuckers.
(audience cheering)
Do you know how pumped I am?
I dream at night, last night
I fell asleep at two o'clock
and I go, one day that
kid's gonna have to change
his profile from
influencer to bank teller.
(audience laughter)
Can't fucking wait.
So, intent,
don't be full of shit
cause you're tricking
the 90% that don't matter
and you're losing
equity with the 10% that do.
Number two, do.
You gotta work, you feel super
inspired from this weekend,
you can't wait, what
happens next Thursday?
What happens next month?
You have to actually work a lot.
You know zero people,
zero people
that have built something big
that haven't put in a
ridiculous amount of work,
and the bigger it is
the more they worked.
So many of you have your mouth
way ahead of your actions.
Really, you're
gonna own an island
and you fucking go
to Cochella, fuck you.
(audience laughter)
Cause it's the truth.
It's the truth and
the reason you say that
is cause you, like me,
have been through
a couple of these cycles.
We know exactly what
we're living through.
All of my 48-year-old
executive employees
were trillionaires in 2000
cause of the internet
and the stock market prices.
You know how many
people here, have a startup,
raised money, and have not
had one month in their lives
where they were profitable?
Let me remind all of you
startups that have raised money,
it doesn't take a hero
to lose money each month.
And there's a problem, and
I'm coming with you with this,
and this is positive fire.
I'm not razzing you,
I'm trying to give you love
because I know what's happening,
I live in that world.
VC money is clamping up.
VC money is clamping up, so I'm
sitting here and telling you
to do, if you are not making
money yet with your business
figure out why.
Change your model.
Cut your overhead.
Shit's coming.
Practicality is my religion.
That's why I push
patience on so many of you,
'cause it's practical.
It is a marathon.
Unless you die
it's gonna be long.
So why are you running so fast,
why do you need it so bad?
Let me tell you
what really sucks.
It really sucks when
you bought a $20,000 watch
and shit hits the fan
and you can't sell that
piece of jewelry for
$4,000 'cause everybody's
trying to get a job.
And so everybody
is not investing.
Let me tell, and by the way,
I eat my own dog food.
From 20 to 30 I built a
business to $45 million a year
business kicking real profit,
and I was paying myself
$47,000 a year living
in a one bedroom apartment
and driving a Jeep Grand
Cherokee, which was nice,
but it wasn't a fucking Beamer.
And I did that cause I was
investing in the
business for a foundation.
And everybody's
trying to make a buck
and they're pulling it out.
You're making money and
you're buying nice suits.
Stupid, short term, insecurity.
(laughs)
(audience applause)
People getting
naked in the front row.
But I mean it, but I mean it.
Right, like there's that
meme, you know it's funny,
it makes me smile and I hope
people are getting something
out of it. There's that
meme from Jay Z on Instagram,
right, like two pictures of
him, one with a ton of jewelry
and then one now
with just a black t-shirt,
and it shows one, he was
like worth a million dollars,
and now, but
really, that's just real.
And the thing that I
don't like, and I've been
bringing it up here and I'm
gonna bring it up again is,
people are fronting for
people that aren't going
to be the impact on them.
I met with a kid for 20
minutes today, loved him,
he's got it, but he's
doing, but, thank you,
but he doesn't, but
he's doing something
that's gonna hurt him.
And I told him, I said,
"Look, you're doing something
"that is not going to win.
I would eliminate you
"from consideration
to do business with
"based on this behavior other
than I don't think I'm shit
"and I shouldn't be judging
people, but most of the majority
"of my contemporaries
are doing that."
I'm just confused by the
behavior of the current system
because so much of it facade,
so much of it is short term,
so much of it is fake, and I
don't know, I just know how
I got here today.
I know how
I got the luxury
and the enormous,
enormous feeling of admiration,
and it came from tried and true.
And it comes from
tried and true for everybody.
And what we do is
we sit around and look
at the .000001%
of a
guy that creates Instagram,
or a guy that creates
Facebook, or Elon Musk,
and we start mapping
towards these anomalies,
yet 99.99999% of people
that have been successful,
it took them 20, 30, 40 years,
tried and true, hard work,
and so I try to impose on
you here today, my friends,
through sheer will trying to
force it down your throat,
that first and foremost
your intent needs to be pure.
If you wanna
build a good business
and you wanna
give back to the world,
then that's what
you actually have to do.
You know, you're
not gonna trick, right,
and then, you know,
I don't know, I'm just,
I'm just very, very,
very passionate about this
because
you're living
through the greatest era
that human beings
have ever lived through,
and I am not confused to
the macro political issues
that we're living through.
And I understand all
the scenarios that we're
living through across the globe.
It's just that humans
have never had it better.
Like your life is better
than your great,
great-grandparents.
There's a lot of shit going
on with political presence
and things of that nature,
yet it's still better
than if the Black Plague was
running through us right now.
Like, we are so fortunate,
the fact that you're even
at this conference puts you at
this, such a small percentage
of people in the world,
we have 7.4 billion people
in this world, and you have
it so good. I am so grateful.
I am so grateful, right, I am
so aware of what's actually
happening here, and
I don't mean for me.
I mean for all of you.
And so, I can't wrap
my head around wasting
the one at-bat we have,
unless somebody here
has got some real interesting
data, we don't come back.
And you know what,
I'm super fucking pumped
that I ended up
being a human being.
It's much more fun
than being an elephant.
And so if you take into
account the ridiculousness
and the utter
quadruple miracle that it is
that you're even
sitting here in a human
and have all this opportunity
that you were a human
during this era, and
you're not willing to deploy
the patience, and the work
ethic, and the tried and true
that it takes to live,
you know how many people here
want to be a millionaire?
Do you know how rare that is?
Have you run the math?
You have this enormous audacity,
you have this enormous
audacity, yet you're
not putting in the work
to get you there
because you think
somehow you've been tricked
by yourself or somebody else
that there's some system,
that there's
some fucking shortcut.
There's no fucking shortcut.
You've gotta put in the work.
Lots of it.
And that comes at the
expense of golfing all the time,
and that comes at
the expense of going
to every god damn event.
And it definitely
comes at the expense
of watching one
more motivational video,
and three more books, and
seven more pod, you have to do.
Doing is the game.
(audience applause)
The remote control of society.
If you sit in this
room and you do not know
how to make written words,
audio sounds, or videos
for this device,
on the 7 to 10 platforms
that dominate it,
Facebook, YouTube,
Instagram, Snapchat,
then you are
invisible to society.
I'm gonna say it one more time.
You know, the
first 80% of this rant
felt really good for
the 50-year-old plus.
The next two minutes
are not gonna feel so good.
(audience laughter)
If you live in the world today
and you do not, at scale,
produce written words,
audio sounds or videos for
this device,
you do not exist,
and you need to wrap
your head around that.
So, the theme of this, in
actuality, is the following.
The answer is self-awareness.
Know who you are,
know what you do,
and then tell it in the way
that comes most natural to you.
If you're a writer, great.
Start posting on Medium,
I've got a great
little recommendation
that a lot of people
aren't talking about.
If you like to write,
write long posts on
Facebook and Instagram.
Get in a company picture,
and write a long-ass blog post.
How many people here are
writing a blog right now?
Raise your hands high.
Tomorrow, write on Facebook,
in addition to, or
move your blog to Facebook.
It will change your world.
Tomorrow.
Audio, how many
people here have a podcast?
Raise your hands.
Couple.
If you don't like to write,
and listen, even
though I've written four
New York Times
bestselling books,
I can't write for shit.
If any of you've
gotten an email from me,
can't put two
sentences together.
God bless ghost writers,
I love you Stephanie Land.
But I can talk.
And so, if you
don't want to be on video,
'cause your conscious
of that, but you can talk,
and you're not a good writer,
you need to start a podcast,
and you need to put
your content on SoundCloud
and Spotify tomorrow.
And, if you've
got the gift for gab
and charisma, and
you like the camera,
and it lights you
up like it does for me,
then you need to
make videos tomorrow
on YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram.
Tomorrow.
If you do not
communicate that intent,
and then when I say go do,
you've gotta build
a business or content,
but it needs to live in here.
There is no other world,
and it is the
modern version of this.
Affiliate marketing and
search and all these things,
they don't play
the same way on this,
and there's nothing else.
I don't even have
a computer any more.
I've lived the last 18 months
of my life with only this.
I look at laptops
like what is that?
The world is shifting
faster than it ever has before,
but the way to
win is as old at time.
Do the right thing,
and put in the fuckin' work.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Oh, we're gonna go
right up to the front.
- I want to get real close.
- All right.
Shit, look at this.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you, brother.
- How incredible is this guy?
(audience cheers)
Holy fuck.
- I'm only incredible
because I'm saying the thing
that so many of you think, but
you do things to cover it up.
You know your
buddy's full of shit.
I just tell my buddy,
you're full of shit,
and then they have
a decision to make,
and so many of those
buddies are like you know what?
I am, and I can deploy
this charisma and gift for gab
if I just swallow it
for three or four years,
I can actually be big,
bigger than I would have been
by selling this
short-term bullshit,
and feel good about myself.
I'm not doing this
'cause this makes me feel good
and I'm like ah, ha.
I'm doing this 'cause
I want you to feel good.
I feel good.
(audience laughter)
- All right, so when I was
in New York and we connected,
you talked about, you
know, business man Gary
and then like Batman Gary.
- Right.
- Right, and I absolutely
loved this idea, this concept.
So, just for a second I want
to talk to business man Gary.
When you're looking at
investing in a company,
like investing in a
business that's up and coming,
what are some of the key
things that you look for?
What's like really important?
- Only two things
I give a shit about.
One, do I believe
in your thesis?
If you walk in and
say I'm building a website
that really
does well on a laptop
and sells ice cream in Alaska,
I'm like oh, that's
a shit thesis, I'm out.
Right?
So, I have to
believe in your thesis.
I believe that meditation
over the next decade
is gonna be the big
consumer space, right?
I feel like, thanks Mom.
(audience laughter)
But what you and I know
is that physical health
has been a 30, 40 year trend,
it is time to talk
about the mental part.
It's the whole game,
it's all I've got.
By the way, if you
dissect me, I'm so basic.
It's just EQ, it's
just very basic things,
it's self-esteem,
it's insecurity, right?
It's very simple,
what I actually talk about.
I update it by the
current state of the world,
but the thesis is
as simple as it gets.
So, what you and I know is that
I believe every
single person here
will be spending
meaningful money on meditation,
whether going to meditation
studios, 'cause it's trendy.
Whether getting
an app so they sleep.
But it's gonna be great.
I'm really excited.
I really, I'm
excited to be like 70, 80
and see the full cycle of it,
'cause it's gonna help so many,
so many people here would
benefit from
mental games, right?
So if you come in
and have a meditation,
if you came in and said I want
to start the clothing brand,
like, remember Tap Out for UFC?
I want to start the clothing
brand for the meditation space,
which seems ridiculous,
'cause the meditation space
in itself isn't fully baked,
and you want to be the clothing,
which has nothing to do with it,
you know, what is it
gonna be, a headband?
I'd still be interested,
(audience laughter)
I'd be interested, because
I believe it's gonna happen.
Then comma, and
equally as important,
probably slightly
more important to me,
is do I believe in her?
Can she do it?
Can she, when shit is tough,
thirteen months in
and money's bleeding,
and she has to
fire her best friend,
and she's not doing
well, and it's lonely,
and she knows that her parents
told her to go to Harvard,
but she did this, and
now she's on the brink,
does she have the
stomach to get through it?
The biggest issue
right now, in 2017,
is entrepreneurship
has become so popular
that characters
like me take selfies
that everybody thinks
they have to be one,
but it takes a
certain kind of makeup,
and everybody's about to
get punched in the mouth,
and most of them are gonna fold
like a bunch of fuckin' losers.
- All right,
that's some real talk.
That's some real talk,
we'll take it.
- So when I invest,
I'm like okay.
If she walked in
and I believed in the
meditation app she's building,
and I really liked her,
I would say okay,
shit's gonna hit the fan,
probably before
meditation gets big,
but there's something
about her that makes me think
that when that
shit hits the fan,
she's gonna turn it
into a cupcake company
and we're still
gonna make money.
That's what I'm looking for.
I'll fuckin'
sell hot dogs tomorrow
if nobody wants to
buy social media content.
I'm just telling
you guys the truth,
that's what I would, I mean,
better than
going out of business.
Love it when people are like
we're gonna go out of business.
I'm like, you're a
bullshit entrepreneur.
Like, you didn't
even try for a second.
The second adversity came you
folded like a cheap chair.
Loser.
(audience laughter)
- So let's talk about that.
Let's talk about
adversity, 'cause I think,
I think this is something that--
- I love it.
- All entrepreneurs
can relate to.
And I mean, yeah, so how
do you deal with adversity?
'Cause it's gonna happen.
- Happily.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Just the one word answer.
I love it.
- Definitely not complain.
I love when people compain,
like somebody walked in
my office the other day,
she's raised $100 million,
her company's huge.
She sits and complains.
I'm like, my friend.
I'm like, you've
raised $100 million,
you've paid yourself a nice
salary for the last six years,
you've lived on your own terms,
you've been on the
cover of magazines,
I'm struggling to
cry for you right now.
Like, you made
your bed, lay in it.
So, I deal with
adversity happily.
I know exactly what to do.
Meaning, you cut your expenses
and you maximize your profits.
And if you were smart,
you knew it was coming
and you're not too over bloated
in one way or the other.
I'm definitely not at the
reliance of somebody else.
So, no VC's, or I've never
raised money for my businesses.
I make money,
I don't give pieces
away of my company for money.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
And so, I don't know,
I just like it.
I think battle
scars are attractive.
- Like it. In terms of
like building Batman
building this like personal,
building this like
personal brand that
you have that you put out,
which is why a lot, you know,
a lot of us are here today.
I'm curious, you talk
about document don't create.
- Yes
- How important is it to
have something to create on?
Because I think,
what you talk about is
you talk about a
lot of these Millennials
and a lot of these
younger people who are trying to
take the selfies and
build an online profile,
but they don't have
something to actually document.
So what does that
look like in your business?
- By the way, it's
not just Millennials,
there's plenty of
40, 50-, 60-, 70-,
80-year-old non-executors, too.
The reason I came up
with document over create
is for people that don't
have something big already.
Like you should
document your journey.
The first
episode should be like,
"Hey, it's me, Rick."
(audience laughter)
Yeah, so, I kinda realized last
night that I'm full of shit.
And, you know, my t-shirt
company isn't fucking Nike.
You know, and so I'm just
gonna talk about my journey.
And I'm gonna go to the gas
station and fill up my car.
I mean like you...
(audience laughter)
I think the only thing
that really sells is truth.
And people always
email me when I say that
they're like look at
this guy they were a scumbag
I'm like yes, that
person eventually goes to jail.
People are just
looking, I don't,
dude I'm struggling out here.
I'm not joking,
I'm struggling out here.
Like, really we're at a place
now where kids think it's cool
if somebody goes and
takes money out of a bank
and puts it on their fucking
bed, and takes a picture of it?
Like what the fuck
is the matter with you?
(audience laughter)
It's gonna be bad and
it's gonna be fucking good.
(audience laughter)
- Alright, so I wanna
back the train up a little bit
because meditation
is something that
I think is really
important, that mindfulness
in the workspace
as entrepreneurs.
We had Moment out here
which is like a tech company
here in Vancouver
that represents
meditation and
meditation in the workplace.
And I think it's
really important.
How do you integrate
that with your employees
and with your team, I'm really
curious as to like how do you
build that within like
the corporate infrastructure?
- Meditation?
- Just mindfulness in general,
or if you haven't done it yet,
do you see it becoming a part
of all work environments?
- I'm a funny entrepreneur.
I'm a bigger fan of
capitalism than communism.
And so, I tend to like really
let my people do their thing.
You know, I don't
like doing things,
you know, I think of myself
as the federal government,
and I think of my business
leaders as like the states
using the
American system, right?
So I don't actually manage,
push down a lot of things
into my company
because you know,
I think companies get
very politically correct
and of the moment.
I don't wanna like,
now everybody has to meditate,
I've meditated once.
Because I
invested in the company.
(audience laughter)
And I fucking hated it.
Doesn't mean that I
don't think it's gonna be huge.
You know, I just
don't wanna do it!
(audience laughter)
So, that's the truth
like, listen I feel good
like maybe if my mental status
changes, maybe I'll be like,
oh maybe that can
help, I don't know
right now, I'm actually
scared to meditate, bro.
I'm so happy I'm like,
that meditation shit
better not fuck me up.
(audience laughter)
I think companies
do politically correct
things and look stupid.
I love when big
companies thought
by putting a foosball table
and giving free cereal out
that that made them like Google.
I'm not a big fan of tactics,
I'm a big fan of religion.
Here's my religion: I give
a shit about my employees.
(audience applause)
I don't need to give them a
foosball table, I don't know,
if Rick wants to go on
vacation eight times a year,
we have unlimited
vacation policy, unlimited.
Now, if you take
eight weeks of vacation,
and you're not dismantling it
the rest of the year,
you're fired.
But, unlimited.
I don't think Millennials
like work-life balance.
I have nothing but
22-year-olds who are like
"I want more money, dick,"
I'm like okay.
(audience laughter)
I'm like work, you know, like
you know I love, you know like
so I think people impose too
much stuff, it's all tactics.
It's what I talked
about with you guys.
The majority of people here
that are solving the world
are in tactics not religion.
They don't mean it.
They're posturing,
companies do that.
They come up with happy
hours and foosball tables,
and free cereal to make
pretend they give a shit.
So, I talk about
my truths, you know
we'll bring in somebody
maybe speak about meditation
but they can or can't
I don't judge on that.
I wanna reverse engineer
every person one by one.
I'm not imposing
my will on them.
Kid walked in the
other day he goes,
"Gary, I'm gonna be the
CEO of this company."
I'm like, bro, good
now here's the problem,
you've already
wasted too much time.
So, you know, whatever.
(audience laughter)
Like you're not gonna
be the CEO of this company
when you took 4.3 weeks vacation
last year, and you're 23.
You need to work 19
hours a day and learn.
- Yep, it's amazing.
- Here's what's fun
- Okay, keep going
- You know what's fun about it?
It doesn't matter
what I'm saying up here.
Like, all I'm repeating
is what the market's doing.
Right, this isn't my opinion,
It doesn't matter that
I'm saying it in a funny way,
sitting a funny way.
This is what the
market does, I'm just saying
it's not me, this is
what the market does.
Like, that's what
people don't understand
I have no opinions, I'm
just observing the market
and just reiterating it.
That's why it's fun,
I don't take it personal,
like, I don't care for the three
people that are gonna tweet
here, after this conference,
tons of good
and there'll be
three people like
I don't like Gary
his ego's too much.
I'm like I don't care
'cause they're gonna be right
or I'm gonna be right.
Maybe they're right.
Maybe my ego's too much and my
head will explode next week.
(audience laughter)
I have a funny
feeling I'm gonna fucking win.
(audience cheers)
And by the way
(audience laughter)
We all have it, right?
Like we all still have
our chips and fun,
I'm really enjoying this
Planet of the Apps thing.
Re/code wrote an article that
said, Planet of the Apps coming
with Gwyneth Paltrow,
celebrity mentors
Gwyneth Paltrow
Will.i.am, Jessica Alba,
and others.
(audience laughter)
And I was so pumped.
Like, I love adversity,
My man, nobody in this room
you could be tied with me,
but nobody in here loves more,
losing, adversity, difficulty.
I'm a wartime general.
I hate this peacetime,
these good times, meh.
This shit that's
about to come, carnage.
Oh God, I'm ready,
I'm so ready man.
- Because you've built your
business out of that adversity.
- Guys, do you know what I did?
Do I have to
remind the eight of you
that knew me seven years ago?
I was at the height, I was
one of the 50 most followed
people on Twitter when
there was no other networks.
I had just invested in
Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr,
I was the guy, I was
hanging out with Mark Zuckerberg
every week that
he was in New York,
I had all the
relationships, I was this
genius predictor of
where the world's going,
and I started an agency.
This is not my words,
these are my actions!
Who gives a shit what I'm
saying, watch what I'm doing.
At the height of
my career to be fancy,
I went and decided
to do client services
and eat shit and have clients.
'Cause I wanted to built a
marketing machine for the future
I decided, let
me take a step back
and build something
for ten years, eat shit
make lots less money,
have lots less fun
not cash in on all
these great things I did,
let me build a foundation
for, you know, 50 to 90.
So, like, I don't know,
like I know I talk a lot
but I promise you, I'm doing
way more than I'm talking.
- How do you, it's interesting
'cause watching your journey
it's almost like
you have this cognition
of what's coming.
How have you developed that?
'Cause I think
that for a lot of us
it's challenging
to see what's coming.
How do you cultivate that?
I think it's so important
it's such an important skill.
- I got a good
answer for you, I lack ego.
Let me explain what I mean
by that, I know that's funny.
(audience laughter)
But I'll tell you
how it happened.
And what I mean by that.
I was one of the first top 50
followed people on twitter.
Ego, kept a lot of those
people staying on twitter
when other things emerged.
They didn't want
Instagram to happen.
Do you know how
many people in here loved
affiliate marketing
web 2002?
Ego kept them
out of social media.
Ego, do you understand?
I know that I ain't shit.
That the market is
the king and the queen
and I respond to it.
So the reason
I'm good like that,
is when new shit emerges
and then I go taste,
and I make judgment calls.
One thing a lot of you know is
I talk about
consumer VR being farther away
than a lot of people think, Why?
Because two and a half
years ago I jumped into VR,
when I tasted it's
beginning, and I used it,
and then I watched it and
now I'm using my experience.
Which is what I love
about 40-,50-,60-,70-,
80-year olds, we've seen it.
You haven't 27-year-old Pat,
you haven't seen it yet.
You will, so I saw it
and I'm like wait a minute
this is internet
1990 the technology's here
but the consumer behavior's not.
There's not a person
in this audience that
knows somebody that
spends two hours a day
consistently living in VR.
So, you know, that to me
is what's really exciting.
Other than people
that are in the industry.
And so, you know,
normal people don't.
And so we're still
a further way away.
And so I taste things and
then I make judgment calls
And that's why, and it
comes from lack of ego.
It doesn't matter that
you won the last thing,
there's a new thing here.
Didn't matter that I won email,
email wasn't gonna
stay at 90% open rates.
It didn't matter
than I won Google AdWords.
Google AdWords weren't gonna
stay at five cents a click
and be the only thing.
And so I just lack, I just don't
read my own press clippings
I just think I'm as
good as my last at-bat.
I think I'm super fancy now
and that if I make
seven bad decisions
nobody's gonna
give a fuck and say
I told you so he was a huckster.
By the way,
that's how the market does it.
- I'm curious, I wanna shift
gears a little bit.
You're talking
about virtual reality.
I'm a huge nerd with AI--
- Okay.
- and I'm curious
how you think AI,
we already have A&amp;I here,
how do you think
AI is going to shape
and shift technology in our
communities and everything?
- It's real.
I call it third and half base.
Anything that AI
and machines can do
to get us to third and
a half base will be done,
and then we're
gonna take it home.
Anything that's being
done now by humans
that computers can
do will be eaten up,
and let me just
remind all of you.
That's a lot.
Driving cars and
all sorts of shit
that we didn't
think about 10 years ago,
so I'm a big fan.
Every single
customer service job
that is in the
business of emailing back
customer service
answers is out of business.
Over the next
three, seven, nine,
12 years, I'm a huge fan.
I'm also very
fascinated by voice.
I'm obsessed with
Alexa and Google Home.
Listen, we care
about time and convenience
and that's it.
That's it.
If I can just be
brushing my teeth,
remember something,
it's quicker for me to say,
"Hey Google
Home," or "Hey Alexa,
"Remind me to buy tomatoes,"
than to grab my
phone and type it.
Just faster. Speed.
Speed wins everything.
Speed wins everything,
speed is absolutely
one of my two or
three religions in business.
Speed. Fast.
Everybody's too precious,
you're overthinking
your content.
You're overthinking
your decisions.
You're better off doing 16
times of being right three times
than not doing anything at all.
You're pondering.
You lack the confidence
because you're
worried about what people say.
I like losing.
That's why this is all so easy.
I don't give a
fuck if you said I lost.
- [Man] Woo!
- It's true.
It's an important thing, bro.
- [Man] Fuck yeah!
- I love your beard.
- [Man] Thanks.
- Beard dude there is
reacting to the right thing,
and I'll tell you why.
By not worrying about
what other people think,
it allows you to do things.
By doing things, you either win
or you learn from your loss,
and it creates speed.
It's the absolute
mental difference
between the people
that are executing winning
versus the people that aren't.
It's the fear of others.
I don't want to lose,
but I'm definitely
more disappointed
than your opinion in
your blog post about my loss.
- I got one last
question for you.
- Cool.
- When we chatted last,
you said that your daughter
has the edge.
She's got the
entrepreneurial spark.
- No, she has
charisma and storytelling.
I don't know if she has
the entrepreneurial spark.
Maybe her environment
of being rich as fuck
is not gonna let her be that.
(audience laughter)
I'm serious.
By the way,
look, she may
look at what Daddy did
and she's gonna look at that
mountain and say, "Fuck that,
"I'm gonna give
all his money away
"to people less privileged,"
and I will support
the shit out of that.
I don't want her to be me,
I want her to be her
and whatever she does,
I'm behind her
one billion percent.
(audience applause)
And I can tell you,
and I'm happy 'cause
she's gonna watch this
one day when she's doing it.
She will win because she's got
the empathy and the charisma,
so whether she's
raising funds for the needy
or she's trying to
climb Daddy's mountain
and say, "Fuck you, Daddy,
I'm doing it bigger."
She will win 'cause she's got it
and it's gonna be cool to see.
It'll be a fun experiment.
Maybe I was me
because I had nothing
and when I wanted toys,
we didn't have
the money for that,
so I had to go sell,
shoveling people's
snow and lemonade,
and that's what did it.
Maybe 'cause she has everything
and has already
done things in her life
that I didn't do
until three years ago
and she had to be on
that private plane with me
'cause we had to go
and things like that.
Maybe she won't
have that hunger.
What she'll have,
I have gratitude and empathy.
Maybe she's gonna have guilt
that she had it so crazy good,
and that
manifests in giving back.
I don't mind.
If she wants to
paint with tomatoes, great.
I just want her to be
fully pure in what loves,
the way I am.
Then, it has a
funny way working out
'cause I'm gonna remind
everybody one more time.
Being an entrepreneur
was not cool
when I was growing up.
It was just the
only thing I knew.
- Amazing.
Well, we're gonna open it up
to Q&amp;A.
- Let's do it.
- I'm gonna jet out the stage.
I'm gonna leave them for you.
I'm just gonna remind everybody
that there are
1,350 people in here
that wanna ask questions,
so try and keep
your questions brief
because there's a
shit ton of people
that wanna ask questions.
We're gonna have mic runners.
I'm gonna leave
the stage with you,
with these monsters,
so good luck.
- Let's clap it up.
- Thank you.
(audience applause)
- [Gary] I'm not in
control of the questions,
people with the mics are.
Let's do it, who's got it?
Go ahead, grab
someone. You're in.
I'm not picking.
- [Man 2] I got a question,
but before I go into it,
I just wanna take a minute
and pay tribute to you, Gary,
because I think that
10 to 50 years from now,
you're gonna go down in history
as one of the greatest
entrepreneurs in the world
like Walt Disney, Thomas Edison.
Give it up for Gary.
- I really think you're right.
(audience laughter)
No ego.
- [Man 2] My question is,
I run a video marketing company,
and in a lot of your keynotes,
I watch all
your keynotes online,
you talk about the importance
of redefining an industry.
What would you recommend
for someone like
me in that industry
as a way that
we can redefine it?
- Do you wanna redefine it?
- [Man 2] Yes.
- Why?
- [Man 2] Because it's boring.
- I think that there's
a couple things here.
Redefining it is fun
for a lot of reasons,
mainly because you have the
audacity to have legacy, right?
That's fun.
It tends to make long-term
money versus short-term money
'cause if you're right,
the video trends
are obvious, right?
There's 360, it's out there.
It hasn't clicked the
way people thought it would,
but it's still
got a long way to go.
All the action is
gonna be in VR in 20 years.
You're young.
I would commit my
whole world to VR video,
wait 'til it becomes a reality,
eat the shit over the
next seven to 12 years
because it's not gonna be there
and you're gonna be selling it,
but nobody's gonna want it.
Do whatever you have to do,
sell hotdogs and
cupcakes to get there.
Then when the market's there,
you were a pioneer.
Guys, nobody wanted social media
when I was talking about it.
I just knew it was gonna happen
and I was willing to eat shit
for a decade to get there,
so that's what I would do.
Cool.
Who's next? How
many mics are there?
Go ahead.
Is there one in the middle?
Why don't you go to the middle?
Two? Got it, okay.
Hey.
- [Man 3] Hi, how are you?
- Super.
- [Man 3] Hi,
how's it going, Gary?
Thanks for the keynote,
great information as always.
- Thank you.
- [Man 3] I watched
your Hamburg keynote,
which was just about a week ago,
and you talked about,
much like what
you're saying today,
how we've been
through a cruel period
for the past
seven or eight years,
and it's gonna come,
the time's gonna come.
- I've been talking
about this for six months now
because I feel it.
By the way, it still
could be two years away.
It just doesn't feel
like it's gonna 10 years away.
- [Man 3] Exactly, and
I'm totally on board with that.
My question is,
for a motivational,
inspiration blog
which is what I have right now,
which is my startup,
we have an ever-growing
social media presence.
We're past that infancy stage
and we're
starting to really grow,
and we doubled down on
social media marketing.
We're putting out
Facebook ads at scale,
Instagram, same thing.
We're putting
out stories, content
and I've been doing it all day.
My question is, for
someone that has doubled down
on social media marketing,
when that time comes,
whether it's today,
tomorrow, two years,
given the landscape
of the market right now,
how would you prepare in
terms of a contingency plan?
- I would do more
social media marketing
when shit hits the fan.
- [Man 3] Awesome.
- Because that's what
you learned from the
first internet bubble.
Everybody saw
the internet bubble,
but it crashed
and then people walked
away from the internet,
but consumers
still were using it.
Just 'cause the stock
market's gonna collapse
and then everybody's
gonna react to that
and the economic
meltdown will happen,
doesn't mean people stop
using Instagram and Facebook.
The real question is,
are you making money
and can you afford to
operate during a shit time?
Because let me
promise you what goes away
when shit time comes.
Shout-outs.
Coconut companies disappear,
so they don't
have money to give you
the fit person $1,000
to post on your Instagram,
so the money goes away.
Can you make money
when the money goes away?
'Cause there's still money,
it's just left
for the A-players.
- [Man 3] Cool, awesome.
Thanks, I agree
with that so much
and you just totally reaffirmed
social media marketing for me,
so thank you.
- You got it, bro.
Yo.
- [Man 4] Yo, hey, hey.
So you've alluded
to a healthy body and
a healthy mind, but
you've also said that
you were open to
PED use, for, you know,
performance enhancing.
Have you ever used nootropics?
I wonder if you are
on any of that kind of stuff
to get through those long
18 hour days?
- Right, I have no
idea what you just said.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 4] Well, you were
on Joe Rogan
and you mentioned--
- Oh, so that I know,
and Joe Rogan,
I don't know what
nootronics is, so I've never
used.
- [Man 4]
Nootropics, modafinil,
perazitam,
any of the things the bullet
proof guy talks about taking,
to get through those long days.
- No, so, real
quick just hold the mic,
because I want to jam on this.
So, it's really funny,
how many people here are first
generation immigrants?
Raise your hands.
So, I don't know if you
guys have these same things,
I grew up in a Russian
family where, if you had
a fever, you had to go to sleep.
Like, that was
the answer to fix it.
So, it's really funny.
My parents, or wife, or
sister, if they were here
right now, they'd be laughing.
I actually get knocked
out if I take a single
Tylenol.
- [Man 4] Okay.
- So, what I was saying
to Rogan is I'm fascinated
in that all, as I've gotten,
now that I'm in the gym
all the time, I'm fascinated
that in 50 year,
or 20 years, people will say
that steroids wasn't as bad as
it was positioned, right?
The way marijuana or
alcohol, but I'm undereducated.
I've never, I don't
even take supplements.
Because, I always
think the people selling it
don't fully know.
And I'm like, fuck it,
like I'm not taking it.
So, I haven't.
I don't know if
that's right or wrong.
- [Man 4] It's a dirty secret of
Silicon Valley that
they all use Piracetam.
- Well, you know what's
really interesting about that?
In these comments on
all these videos I put up,
everyone's like,
this guy's on coke, right?
(audience laughter)
- [Man 4] No,
I'm not saying you are,
I just wanted to know
what your thoughts are.
- No, my thoughts are,
I don't really judge people
for doing shit, right?
I don't think that's my place.
I don't do anything,
but I don't know
if that's right or wrong.
- [Man 4] Do you know
anyone who does it?
Have you been
around it in that world?
(audience laughter)
Not coke.
- Oh, I know a lot
of people that do coke.
(audience laughter)
I know way more people that
do coke than do steroids, bro.
I don't,
listen I think, listen.
Bro, we're living in
a school system that is
pushing medicine
down kids throats.
Of course they're
gonna be 23 and do shit.
They were taught
that they were too "ADD"
and had to go on
fucking medicine, because big
pharma figured out their way in.
Fuck that.
I aint taking
shit ever mother fucker.
(audience laughter and applause)
And so, you have
parents that lack self esteem
'cause they worry
about what the other parents
say about their kids
that get D's and F's,
and they put their
fucking kids on medicine,
you fucking loser parents.
(audience applause)
One man's point of view.
I gotta go with the
mic, where's the mics?
Somebody talk with a mic.
Mics, you gotta make
decisions here, let's go.
- [Woman] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Woman] Hi, Gary I love you.
- I love you, too.
- [Woman] What is one
thing that you
believe to be true that
most people think is crazy?
- Oh, that's a good question.
What do... One more time?
- [Woman] What's one thing
that you believe to
be true that most
people think is crazy?
- Most of it.
That's a really good question.
You know, usually can
answer these pretty quickly,
I don't know, I think that,
so I think the
truth is undefeated.
Like, I actually believe that
it all works out in the end.
I think people are
very cynical
and think that a lot of people
get away with things.
But, I think that
people don't understand, like,
the macro of things.
They might've gotten
away with the way you judge,
which is they
made a million bucks.
But, I know they
don't sleep at night,
and their lives suck.
So, I would say that
I blindly am optimistic,
and I believe that
the market is the market,
and the truth is the
truth, and so I believe
in that and
I think most people don't.
(audience applause)
Questions?
Mics, only, where are the mics?
- [Allie] Hi Gary.
- Hi,
- [Allie] Down here,
straight ahead.
Straight ahead.
- I see you now.
- [Allie] Okay,
hi Gary I Allie Davis,
lovely to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Allie] I wanted
to speak to you
particularly
about family business.
- Okay.
- [Allie] We've got
an interesting
and unconventional
dynamic evolving.
- Okay.
- [Allie]
I'm the 50-year-old,
and I've only just
gotten into digital.
- Yes.
- [Allie] We took our son,
who's 13 out of
school because...
- 1,3? Thirteen?
- [Allie] 13.
- Keep going.
- [Allie] We took him
out of school 'cause
we don't believe in the system,
and we're educating in
alternative ways.
- Okay.
- [Allie] He's starting
to get involved in
the business doing the
digital stuff, which this
50-year-old struggles with.
- Yes.
- [Allie] Now, so,
he's interested in it,
he's getting involved,
he's only 13.
So, we've got this
unconventional family business
thing evolving with
a 13-year-old, and a
50-year-old, and what's
most important to me is
my family.
- Of course.
- [Allie] So for you,
who's been involved
in a family business,
for many years, what's the
most important thing
for me to know and do,
as a parent of a 13-year-old,
who's already wanted to be
involved in business?
- That's a great question,
thank you for asking it.
Hold the mic for a second
'cause there might
be a follow up.
So, I got involved in
my dad's business in a very
serious way at 14,
probably not as serious as this
sounds, because I only
worked every weekend and
summer vacation,
there's a chance he could be
involved day-to-day.
- [Allie] He is.
- There's one thing my dad
and I did, that in hindsight
I can't believe most
family businesses don't,
my dad and I loved each
other more than the business
by one quarter of a
thousandth of an inch.
(audience laughter)
So, your answer's very simple,
no matter what, no
matter how big it gets,
you just need to
actually back up your words,
if you actually just
love your family more,
then it should be very easy.
- [Allie] It will be easy,
because you're right,
I'm dedicated to my business,
but I'm devoted to my family,
they'll always have the edge.
- Now, I'll say
this and I love this,
it gets hard,
because what happens is
people don't realize,
it's not about the money
after a while.
It's about respect.
And that gets blurred.
Like, me and my dad,
both sort of stunningly
don't give a shit about money.
But, respect, and
honor, and who did it,
those things can get blended
and that's where it gets hard.
So, keep an eye out for
that, because that bleeds
more into family,
'cause people think it's a
money thing/family thing,
it's not,
the money's completely
not the factor.
It's the way you guys interact.
And by the way, your
relationship with your
son, will never be the
same, you know that right?
- [Allie] Yeah.
- When you go into
business with somebody,
it changes everything forever.
You'll have a
different relationship.
And by the way,
my dad and my brother,
both my partners
in my two businesses,
we have
phenomenal relationships,
and I would never
do anything different.
But, it is different.
And it's gonna change.
And, so you need to
be prepared for that.
- [Allie] Thank you,
and I see it
changing already,
and him being the leader,
because he looks
over my shoulder when I'm
watching some of your
videos, and this whole
digital thing, 'cause
I'm from a conventional
business background,
has been quite scary for me.
And, one day he looked
over my shoulder while I was
diddling about, oh
god, (mic cuts out)
and he says,
Gary Vaynerchuk would say,
just fucking do it.
(audience laughter)
- I love it.
Amazing.
Next question, yep.
- [Elijah] Hey Gary.
- Hey.
- [Elijah] My name
is Elijah, I too, ate shit.
So, we've got that in common.
- I love it.
- I read a story about you
when you were young.
One of the first, kind of,
engagements you had
with Ricky Henderson.
(Gary laughs)
And, how you kind of
described it as you changed from
being a fan to being a fanatic.
- Yes.
- [Elijah] I wondered
if you could
kind of describe that,
as well as like,
what does it translate
on a day-to-day basis,
with what you're doing today?
- Got it.
So, you've got me
completely pegged.
It's one of the signature
moments of my career.
I went to my first
baseball game in 1985,
Ricky Henderson was an
outfielder for the Yankees,
he was coming off the
field and he winks at me.
Now, important part,
the crowd's big,
like watch this, 40 people
think I just winked at them.
(audience laughter)
So, I'm hoping he winked at me,
but, I'm not completely sure.
Here's what happened, basically,
for the next seven years,
I bought all his baseball
cards, it was the t-shirt that
I bought. I talked about him,
I became his biggest advocate.
In the same way as me
growing up listening to
Richard Pryor, and
Chris Rock, and Eddy Murphy,
has clearly affected the
way I communicate on stage,
(audience laughter)
I do believe that somewhere,
and when I wrote that article,
that you're referring to,
it was when I realized,
holy shit, the way
I'm treating social media,
is probably because ...
All I'm trying to do at
this point, besides operate,
when I do the GaryVee thing,
I'm trying to figure out
why I did it, how I got there,
and then I'm trying
to tell you, so you
can do it too, right?
So, I'm really
getting in myself, really.
Like, I'm starting to
hit up high school friends,
junior high friends,
grammar school friends, lately,
on social and try to ask them
if they remember anything.
Like, I'm really trying
to bring out more stuff.
You don't need to hear
the same shit over and over.
I'm trying to bring value.
Yeah, there's a big reason
I'm liking everybody's comments,
and replying and
DM'ing you randomly.
I think it's impactful.
I think it feels nice,
if Randy "The Macho
Man" Savage in 1992,
liked one of my tweets I would
have lost my fucking mind.
- [Elijah] Oh, yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Elijah] A follow up to that,
or just expanding on that,
what did, I know you
described it, I don't know if
there's a difference in Canada,
what's the greatest
arbitrage in social media
today, and I'll let you go.
- Oh, it's the same in Canada.
Facebook ads,
Instagram influencers,
there's nothing close.
You should spend
all your money on it,
if you're marketing, to
anybody under the age of 65.
Like 50 to 80-year-old Canada
data on Facebook is crushing.
Like, you can reach
most 72-year-old Canadians,
on Facebook.
At the cheapest price.
It's not that you're
going to reach all of them.
Not all of them
are on there, but if you
actually want to get to
the most, at the best price,
it's called Facebook.
- Cool, who do we have?
Awesome, let's do it.
- [Man 5] Yo, what's good homie?
So my question is,
how do you know when
your ego's in the
way of things your doing?
- I'm not sure, like
for every individual person.
I would say that,
I would say that if
you're allowing your ego
to get ahead of
your humility and
self-awareness it's
clearly going to be in the way.
I think you need to pull
very hard from both sides.
They both matter tremendously.
And it's just, you
can't believe how truthful
it feels in my heart and stomach
when I say, I aint shit.
And I agree with
the kid that says
I'm gonna be one of the greats.
I just believe in
both of them, I just do.
I just do.
I also think that if
you're one of the great
entrepreneurs of
a generation doesn't
necessarily mean
you're so special.
It means you were
good at that craft.
What I'm trying to do
is be a little bit special.
Nobody goes to
somebody's funeral 'cause
they made $40 billion.
They go to the funeral because
that person did
something that made them
feel like they should
have went to the funeral.
So I'm trying to do both.
And so I would say,
that ego gets
ahead of a lot of people.
But I think it's really hard
to analyze that from afar.
Here's what I would say,
if you aren't 100% happy,
something's wrong so
start auditing everything.
Cool.
Yo.
- [Man 6] Hey Gary, first of all
I just wanted to say,
when I first heard you,
man, I thought you
were a snake oil salesman.
- I get it.
- [Man 6] And I'm so glad
I didn't give up on listening
to you because you're...
- Why didn't you?
- [Man 6] You know it
was when you
started talking from
the heart that really it,
something about
it touched me and
I just really appreciated
what you were saying.
- So wait in the
same video, you're like
fuck this guy he's a snake oil
salesman and wait a minute.
- [Man 6] You know what?
The first video
I stopped watching and
then somebody
I know posted a link and
I followed that one through and
loved what you
said on that one and
since then I've just
gone down the rabbit hole.
- Let me talk
about that for a second.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- That's what
I mean by the truth.
It doesn't hurt me
if people think that
because I know
my personality and
it makes sense to me why
somebody would think that.
It also doesn't
bother me because
I know how it's gonna end up.
Go ahead.
- [Man 6] I'm not even sure
why I started
that way other than
just to tell you how much
I appreciate what you're doing.
- I appreciate it man.
- [Man 6] I'm working on
an idea right now.
- Actually watch this,
how many people
in this audience
started off not liking me?
(cheering)
Stand up, I want
everybody to see it.
(audience laughter)
Let me tell you what that is.
That is either very quick
consumption where they just
caught one sound
bite where I was being
my ego self, and/or,
they didn't want
to face their truth
and I was suffocating them.
Go ahead.
- [Man 6] So I guess I'm asking
you this question cause I know
you get a lot of
ideas come your way.
- By the way I'm never doing
that again, that fucking hurt.
- [Man 6] Yeah sorry, buddy.
(audience laughter)
- It still hurts.
- [Man 6] I didn't mean
to hurt you.
- Still hurts, Jesus.
- [Man 6] Everybody in here
loves you now though.
- I get it.
Go ahead.
- [Man 6] All right so,
I'm looking
for a way to
use fitness tracking
to create monetary
opportunities for people.
- Okay.
- [Man 6] Like to raise money
with your running, your walking,
your cycling though pledging.
- Interesting.
- [Man 6] I'm just curious if
you've seen anything
come across your desk
like that or if you've?
- Sure.
I've seen a ton of
things that are, do this action
and that action
will create the funding.
- [Man 6] Right, I'm looking for
the unknown unknown.
Like what should I be
looking at to figure out
where I need to
go with this thing?
Like I'm pretty
early in my hustle on this.
- First and foremost
you should get very serious
about B-to-B not B-to-C.
- [Man 6] All right.
- So big companies like
to support shit like that
'cause it makes them look good.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- Right?
Most people don't give a fuck.
Right?
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- Like I mean, but
there's one place I would look.
Go reverse engineer
and study everything
about what Charity: Water did
when they did donate
your birthday, right?
They found something
there technology-wise
and theme-wise, right?
So I would say two things,
case study on
Charity: Water
donating your birthday.
Know everything about the
psychology of why that worked.
And number two
realize that the only way
you're gonna get
past the first inning
is get corporations to
subsidize the donations,
'cause most people won't do it.
- [Man 6] Right on,
thanks a lot Gary.
- Cool, you got it.
Hey.
(audience applause)
Can I go late?
(audience cheering)
I can go late a little bit.
Yeah? Yeah, cool.
Hey.
- [Laura] Hello.
- Hello, hey.
- [Laura] What's up?
- All good.
- [Laura] Okay,
I'm gonna come up closer
just cause I want to
speak to you face-to-face.
- Okay.
- [Laura] First of all
I gotta say
this feels like
being at a wax museum
when you see those
famous people in person.
Yeah, except you're much
better looking in person.
- Thank you.
I thought you
were calling me waxy.
(audience laughter)
Okay.
- [Laura] My name is Laura.
Just to give you a
little bit of context
before I ask my
question, what really resonated
with me a lot about your life
is that I'm a first
generation immigrant.
And when you said
that you couldn't afford
a Jets jersey
and that's your dream
to own New York Jets.
For example,
myself, I never owned
a single brand name
handbag in my life.
- Right.
- [Laura] Up until last year
when I got to manage
the number one top
volume handbags floor
in one of the top department
stores in North America.
- That's awesome.
- [Laura] So from there,
currently aside
from managing the handbags
floor at a department store,
because we are a public
company I can't share that.
When I get off my work I
work for the VR Association
'cause you touch a
lot on virtual reality.
So I spend about
15 to 20 hours a week
unpaid marketing work,
doing marketing work
for VR Association and
I just recently got a job,
another job, my third job,
at a VR company.
And I kind of
want to see, my job,
my goal is
to connect retail
experiences with virtual reality
and for you before,
within your lifetime
for myself to
come up with a solution
that you don't
have to go into a store--
- Okay.
- [Laura] To shop for clothing,
and my question for you is,
so I come from a family
background, as an immigrant,
where it's been
tough financially.
And I'm at a place
where I'm making my own money
but my parents
have a lot of debt.
So for me to start my
own business my family
thinks that it's very selfish.
- Okay
- [Laura] I get it.
I went through the
traditional route where
I went to a credible
post secondary school.
I paid, well my
parents paid $25,000 a year
on top of my
brothers tuition, which was
another $30,000 a year.
That's reality.
- So what's the punchline?
- [Laura] I'm just saying,
is it selfish for me,
for example...
- Do your parents want you to
get a job and pay them back?
Let me understand
what you're saying.
- [Laura] I'm just thinking,
I take that as my
own burden as well and
do you think that
that's something that
my parents should deal with?
- [Gary] Well did you guys
discuss it before it happened?
- No, but it's just.
- Are you asking me if you
should pay your parents back?
- [Laura] Yeah.
- Yes.
- [Laura] Well in the
long run yes,
but it's just.
- Yes.
But if you decide to take,
do I think you should
get a job and
pay them off slowly
while the
interest compounds versus
taking the risk to
build something big?
- Well in terms of short run,
for example my
mom works right now.
She's like 55 years old,
57 years old.
She makes $10 an
hour and every now and
then I'm trying to
make my own money and
trying to build money
to start my own business.
Where every now
and then she'll ask me,
hey can you
pitch in for my rent?
And I've been paying
for her rent and it's hard.
- Look, I'm not here to
give people family advice
'cause it's hard.
- [Laura] Right.
- I think you need to,
so we can move on here,
I think you need to
answer one question.
What's gonna make you
feel good about yourself?
That's what you should do.
If it feels better, to me this
should not be very difficult.
You should pick and
choose different moments
when you feel like you
want to pitch in on rent,
pitch in on rent.
When you feel
like, fuck that I want
to save so I can
do my thing, do that.
- [Laura] Okay.
- Awesome.
- [Laura] I just have
one more question.
- No way, not with
that fucking long question.
(audience laughter)
Hey.
- [Simsai] Hey Gary,
Simsai here.
I just want to say that
unlike half the room here
I fell in love
with you when I read
Crush It! many years ago.
- Thank you.
- [Simsai] Totally connected.
Before I ask my
question I want to thank you
for liking my Bret Hart
comment on YouTube
at 2 A.M. yesterday.
(Gary laughs)
My question is, you always
talk about the long game.
- Yes.
- [Simsai] And it's
worked for me.
- Go figure.
- [Simsai] I did 11 years of
paycheck to paycheck
and my 12th year
I became a great success.
- Good.
- [Simsai] Unfortunately,
a lot of my clients,
family and friends
in the same space
are struggling and
they have the same hopes
and dreams that I do.
- Okay
- [Simsai] And many of us, a lot
are talking about
depression and suicide earlier.
- Yes.
- [Simsai] And
I struggled with it.
It almost cost me my marriage.
- Yes.
- [Simsai] And what can you tell
to others because you are the
influencer of influencers,
what would you say to this room?
Because I have a
lot of friends here
who struggle with it or
have struggled in the past.
- Listen man, everybody's
struggling with something.
My mom loves to tell
the story about her dad,
who I met but
I don't remember because
he died when I was
like two and a half.
That he'd,
basically the Russian term
would say like
everybody's got their problems
in their rooster hen.
Like basically
everybody's got shit.
What I would say is this,
you know this is
the reason I don't like
fake entrepreneurship.
Because I think it
leads to people feeling down
on themselves in a game
that they were forced into
by the narrative when
they weren't cut out for it.
So what I would say
is like, most people
get depressed
because they're worried
about external
factors not internal factors.
And I don't know a
lot about psychiatry and
all that stuff but
people need an outlet
to get their poison
out of their stomach.
So the only tangible thing
I feel comfortable saying is,
if you're struggling,
you need to communicate
that to somebody
who isn't one of your
three closest
family members 'cause you're
just putting
your baggage on them.
That I believe in.
And so they need
to find that outlet.
- [Simsai] All right, thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applause)
- We staying here,
where we going?
Thanks brother,
nice shirt by the way.
Purewow's a
company I invested in.
I'm giving Ryan a shout-out.
He's very happy
right now watching this.
- [Woman 2] Hi Gary.
- Hey.
- [Woman 2] So you
said earlier that the truth
is what sells.
- Yes.
- [Woman 2] My question is,
is there such thing
as being too honest?
- No.
- [Woman 2] Okay well.
(audience laughter)
- [Woman 2] I know you
don't like hypotheticals.
- Is it a hypothetical
or are you disguising?
- [Woman 2] So I'm going to go.
I have a background and
I've been an entrepreneur
since I was 19.
I've worked for
myself since I was 19.
- Okay.
But my background is in the
adult entertainment industry.
- In the what?
- [Woman 2] Adult entertainment.
- Adult, porn?
- [Woman 2] No.
- I'm sorry,
adult entertainment.
- [Woman 2] Dancing
and escorting.
- Respect.
- [Woman 2] And then I
now own an online virtual
assistant service
to high-end escorts
where we do, or
basically female CEOs
as I communicate with them.
- Okay.
- [Woman 2] But my concern
is I'm making the transition
into a more public,
I have an alias there
and my real name,
blah-blah-blah,
everything's legit.
My concern is you know
you say the truth sells.
I'm concerned about
being really honest.
But what happens
when I work with clients?
I'm transitioning into coaching.
- Okay.
- [Woman 2] Working
with women and people.
When I share my story
they have breakthroughs.
But my question is
more in social media.
Where is the agreement
reality in the marketplace
and the trend for
that type of truth?
Yeah so look,
I think that it's crazy.
There are people that
will judge you and that won't.
I just think you just
got to roll with your truth.
It would be insane,
if you were pitching me
a business right now,
that wouldn't even run
through my mind as a negative.
And somebody sitting
next to me would think
that's the worse thing
that they've ever heard
and never want to talk to you.
You're going to have to
play out and let the chips
fall where they are, right?
Meaning you don't
even need that on your head
and on your chest worrying
about people finding out.
It's just better for you to own
it than to let somebody else
own it above you.
(audience applause)
- [Woman 2] Thanks.
- You're welcome.
Let's do it.
You're about to, I think.
- [Braxton] Okay, Braxton.
- Braxton.
- [Braxton] Yeah, so
I'm starting an energy drink
with a strong
point of differentiation.
I'm just sort of, it's
got a dilemma if I should
develop the brand as
itself or if it should have
a strong personality
behind it, like with your brand,
for example.
You're inextricable
from your brand.
Not least of which
your name is in it.
But when I think of your brand,
VaynerMedia, I think of you.
Right?
- I'm listening.
- [Braxton] Same with
Steve Jobs with Apple.
Whereas if you've got
like Google you don't think
of Larry Page or Sergei Brin.
I'm curious if
you have a preference?
- Notice how both work.
- [Braxton] Yeah, but I'm
wondering if you would think
that one or the other
would be better if it was
different than how it
is and what your general
explication on that would be.
- Nope, so both work.
Both have worked forever.
There's plenty
of quadrillionaires
that you've never
heard of and you don't
associate them with.
I think your bigger
dilemma is you're going
into the beverage industry.
(audience laughter)
I'm not, meaning you
know how hard that is, right?
- [Braxton] I
will I guess, yeah.
- Well let me
give you a preview.
You're going up
against the biggest companies
in the world who basically
have the best model down
which is they pressure
any retailer when any drink
gets any leverage
to kick them out
or then they don't
subsidize the trade dollars.
They've basically, it's really
one of the most gangster
businesses in the world.
- [Braxton] I see
with like Richard Branson,
they did that
with his Virgin Cola.
- Yeah, and I feel like he
had a better start than you.
(audience laughter)
- [Braxton] It's possible.
- But you know what's
awesome about the market?
You might be that one,
but I think before
you worry about
should I build my personal
brand and coinciding with that,
you need to realize
you're going into a gunfight
with a pebble.
- [Braxton] I'll aim well.
- And that's right, so you
should be spending zero time
on that which clearly has
been historically played out
that both work,
and you should do you.
And you need to
figure out how you're going
to distribute and make
this product profitably
in a world where you're going
up against very difficult
political infrastructure.
- [Braxton] Cool, thanks.
(audince applause)
- [Mary] Hello Gary.
- Hello.
- [Mary] Hello, I'm Mary,
I'm really glad to meet you
and I'm really
nervous right now.
- Don't worry,
I'm super far away.
(audience laughter)
- [Mary] Now that
they're all looking at me.
I'm a marketing consultant
and I help clothing stores.
- Okay.
- [Mary] So clothing retailers
and I'm going to ask
a selfish question.
- They normally are.
- [Mary] Do you have
any ideas or tactics on how
I could reach them
and give them value?
- So reach them and give
them value so they hire you?
- [Mary] Eventually yeah.
- Do you know the names of the
people that would hire you?
- [Mary] Yeah.
- Great, so I would follow
them on every social network.
Figure out what they care
about outside of their job
and then I would talk to
them on social networks
around their interests,
not their job.
Don't talk to me
about social media,
talk to me about
the Jets and Bret Hart
and you'll get to me quicker.
- [Mary] All right,
thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
By the way, that tactic I just
said, everybody should do.
Anybody that you're trying
to sell to you need to follow
on every single platform.
Know who they are, and then
exploit that to get their money.
- [Beard Dude] Hey Gary.
- Hey man.
- [Beard Dude] Beard Dude.
- Beard Dude, I'm
glad you came out.
- [Beard Dude] Thanks,
so my question is the reason
I love you is because
you talk about eating shit.
- Yes.
- [Beard Dude] And it's
the hardest thing to do.
- That's why so few people win.
- [Beard Dude] Exactly,
and you talk about the joy,
you love failing.
You love losing and that's a
mentality that's so important.
So I was wondering if
you could just spend a little
more time talking to
us about what it takes
to re-engineer our neural
relationship to pain and losing?
- I don't know,
I think that's a really
interesting question.
I don't know how to create that.
I don't know why
any time I watch a sport
that I root for the
underdog, every time.
I make fun of all
my friends who are fans
of the best teams
because I'm like really?
You need to jump on a
bandwagon to feel
better about yourself?
Like, you're really
wrapping your self-esteem up
into a team that
you didn't care about
but they just won and
you bought their t-shirt?
You're the ultimate loser.
So I don't know why I do that.
I don't know how that happened.
I do believe some
of that is upbringing.
I do think that's the
underdog entrepreneur,
immigrant thing.
I do think that's there.
I definitely am not
the person that knows how
to engineer that, but I
do think that I'm adding
to the conversation.
There's not a lot of
people out there right now
that look like me
that are talking about
the love of losing.
Then if you capture
admiration maybe then
they think that's good.
I'm very driven by
Steve Jobs' narrative.
I just want everybody to know.
Him becoming the famous
person of Silicon Valley
when I was really
deeply in it and the narrative
that he was
tough on his employees
and treated them like shit.
I watched smart, nice kids
start treating their employees
like shit because they
looked up to Steve Jobs
and they thought that
was the right thing to do.
The reason I'm talking
about all these true things
is I hope there's a
15-year-old girl that's looking
up to me on the
internet right now
and she tries to treat people
better because she thinks
I'm cool and that's my system.
(audience applause)
So I don't know how to do it,
but if I'm actually
going to be influential
and if I have a big
responsibility with all the
attention that I have right now,
I think just in the fact
that I'm talking about
it has already impacted
others to think about it.
Thanks man.
- You're kicking me off, huh?
Can I get one more in?
- One more.
- Alright, cool.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 7] Hi, I'm--
- You know I'm going to
get more than one, right?
(audience laughter)
- [Man 7]
(laughing) I was able to.
I am very thankful to
be able to speak with you
and thank you for being here.
I got this ticket because,
I'm going to ask you a
question that in a sec,
but I have to thank you
because two years ago,
I was paralyzed
and I couldn't walk.
(Gary sighs)
I am actually still
walking with a brace.
(audience applause)
No, it's (laughing)...
(audience cheering)
I've been training martial
arts for 21 years of my life
and to have lost everything
and my ability to walk.
Man, there was three
people who helped me, my family,
close friends
and your videos, man.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, man.
- [Man 7] Yeah, fuck.
And (clears throart) it
was a video actually you were
talking about, you know, what
are you 20, 30-years-old,
like what are you going to do
with the rest of your life?
You still have
time, do something
and honestly, it
was so motivating.
So thank you man.
- Thank you man,
means a lot to me.
- [Man 7] Thank you,
my question is,
is now I started a
company for self-defense
because there was a
lot of sexual assaults
that was happening in
and around UBC and SFU
and I was tired
of people being a
victim like I was, I guess.
- Sure.
- [Man 7] And I wanted to
do something about it.
So, I made this
self-defense company
and I have a great deal of
students and one of things,
one of the challenges
that I face all of the time
with some of these
students is anxiety
and how I can help them--
- Yeah.
- [Man 7] See that
they are, you know,
they can do more than they think
and that they're
stronger than they know.
How would you, hiring
someone who is new, say,
and you see that
they have this talent
and potential, how
would you articulate
or explain to them--
- You know how I'd do it.
I'm doing it.
I'd put pressure
on the true answers.
I'd ask them why, did
their mom fuck them up?
I'm being serious.
Insecurity is the seed
that creates all these issues.
- [Man 7] Absolutely.
- And so I'm trying
to figure out why
they didn't build self esteem,
who didn't build self esteem.
And the reason I bring
up mom, is like, Jesus,
it's such a big
percentage of it.
Mom or dad, is like 80% of it.
It's just, you
know, I do this a lot.
Listen, my dad, listen,
I don't talk a lot about this,
that's what happened to my dad.
My dad, I am so
impressed by him.
The way my grandmother
parented my dad,
it's unacceptable. That's the
only word I can think of
and not only that,
they did it and then,
you know I have a lot
of empathy for my grandma.
They did it in the worst place
in the world, Soviet Russia.
So, I'm fascinated by it
because I had the reverse.
I'm so perfectly parented by
my mother, I'm unstoppable.
So, I look at that and
I'm like, how, like, I feel,
I,
I feel guilty that I'm
so emotionally grounded
and strong, that's
why I'm giving it to you.
What do you
thinks happening up here?
I feel guilty that I have
it so good mentally.
There's nothing anybody
can do to my mental state.
It's insane.
I am so weird, guys.
(audience laughter)
Nothing hits, it's like I'm numb
and so I go right to the core.
I do it when I see it sometimes.
I'm like, hey,
you are unbelievable
and you think
you're shit, that's bad.
We need to talk about this,
tell me everything
about your childhood.
(laughs) Like, you
know, and I just go there
and you know sometimes
you get a little break,
but what's really fun is
they start thinking about it
and it changes behavior.
I get an email
every day that says
that they disconnected
from somebody
in their inner circle
and for the last six months,
they're breathing for the
first time in their lives.
It is not easy to
break up with your brother.
break up with your spouse.
It is not easy to
break up with your father,
but that's
actually the binary move,
if they're the
poison of your life.
And we don't talk
about that, none of us,
but it's the truth
and we all know it.
So, A, if that's your
reality, you need to think,
'cause guess what you have
one life and you don't want
to be 73 when
your parent passes away
and finally start breathing.
B, if that is not your life,
you need to drive home right now
and kiss your
parents in the face.
So that's what I do.
(audience cheering)
- [Man 7] Thank you, man.
Thank you, man, thank you.
- Thank you, man.
- Alright.
- Alright, one more.
- I got to rope you off.
- One more, one more.
- I got to rope you off, man.
- I got to rope you off.
- No, no, no, no, don't.
- No, no.
- I got to rope you off.
- Okay, fine.
- These people got to go.
- Thank you.
- They got to go, give
him a round of applause.
Stand up, stand up.
(audience applause)
Stand up.
- Thank you
(audience cheering)
- Got the selfies,
oh my god, the selfies.
Holy smokes.
It's like the bomb rush.
Okay, hold on, hold on, before
like sheer chaos ensues.
Before sheer chaos, oh my god.
We got something for you though.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Boom, there we go.
- [Gary] Alright.
- We're going to have
time, don't worry, don't worry.
- Bye guys.
- Alright, I got
something for you.
- Okay.
- I got something
for you, hold on.
Remember those nice
kicks that you liked?
- Ew, these are fucking fly.
- So that's from 604,
I know how much you love kicks.
- Yes.
- From 604, a local company.
- Amazing.
- Got them done up for you,
a limited edition
from a local artist.
- Fucking rad, thanks so much.
- Awesome, thanks brother.
Thank you.
- Thank you guys
for your attention.
("Space" by Jura Kez)